hey John I liking you do you liking me a
I liking you very much roxan I would say
my liking for you is on the rise ooh hey
I would say that uh mine is not under
the world but over the moon yep yes for
people who haven't figured out what
movie you're watching they might be like
what the weird was that underworld Rise
of the
L we are here this is the third one yes
we watched the first two together did
and people were like can't wait for you
to get to this one because I hear sexy
oh I'm excited then that's all I watch
movies for is is that yeah well I'm a
lover of love a shipper ship ships
that's right but last one was a little
steamy so this might get even hotter and
heavier which might mean that we like it
more which might mean that you liking
this video woo just like the video I
don't think you can actually like in a
video it's Halloween month if it ever
was possible it be now that's very true
don't forget to subscribe hit the
notification all that stuff leave a
comment let us know do you liking this
one the best I can't help it it's the
only pun I have on this one it is right
there if you want to be the Super
sexiest of all the sexy people go over
to patreon where our full length
Reaction watch alongs are you sync up
with your own copy and that's how you be
a leather wearing sexy person the
patreon wears leather that's true over
on patreon that's where Greg and John
cover several shows exclusively with
reaction highlights and watch alongs
included but now we're going to go under
world rise of the lyans with you let's
do it I don't know what that voice is
it's your announcer voice an underworld
Rise of the
lyans Ron joxy and in the house baby Ron
Joy drippy moist let's go oh yeah this
is going to be so drippy and so moist
this movie actually get that sense yeah
I almost came in with wet hair just to
be in character but I was like you know
what I'll I'll spare you guys I have
enough gel in my hair that it's almost
wet good and you're here for the both of
us you're
welcome I wonder if this has the same
cast I bet it would I mean I hope it
does it would be weird if they just
recast everybody right well we're going
I think we're
prequel but might not have your
boy no gra Anatomy boy uhoh Scott
Speedman yeah there's no way we have him
two decades had passed since the
creation of both species the war had
begun okay Victor increased his army
creating a legion of vampires to protect
them from the very first clan of
werewolves unable to take human form
ever again yes we've heard about them
learned about these guys last time until
he was born
oh oh look at the little baby oh Lucian
yes it's my boy yeah we love as a as a
boy a very young wow and although every
fiber of Victor's Soul warned him to
slay this child my man is out here you
know like that's a real actor that's a
real ass baby yes that is an actor
that's a thespian right there do they
publish his name they must he possessed
a strength and focus that the ones
before him did not get a sad card for
that baby cry yeah that's
dialogue oh
yeah it's giving mowgly little bit
Yeah if mowgly learned from one kind of
animal shall we make more of him like
him Lucien will always be the first of
the breed the first of the Likens oh
patience zero they do a good job with
their eyes I mean that's the one
tempting thing about being a vampire
cool eyes taking advantage of the
child's thirst it against him as he was
forced to feed on
humans make this guy eat
people
oh oh yeah I wonder what the werewolf
Transformations are going to be like
this movie
oo he created a new waste of Immortals
lyans werewolf but also human more human
than human this new breed could be
harnessed enslaved to guard them in the
daylight hours of their masters whoa you
could be one of these guards cuz the
ponytail oh you really think so I'm with
you they got a kind of werewolf for
everything
the rise of Skywalker yes oh wait
different movie Lucian Skywalker is
going to be his name by the end of the
movie werewolves have killed their
slaves humans upset Tannis please take a
note of what pain that brings me
Tannis have I not increased our Holdings
tfold since Marcus and the media took
their sleep we will deal with the Wolves
as we always
have props to Bill Nye for always
showing up I was just thinking about
what a legend he is yeah I want to watch
Love Actually after this yes double
feature lyans actually are all around
[Laughter]
us I feel them in my
fingers I feel blood in
myse this is
wicked o this already looks better than
the first two
technology it's technology innovate a
difference W
yeah
eyes Victor doesn't mess around bro nope
oo
oh that was sick
Wicked ah so close damn
dude oh Rona MRA
have you nothing better to do blacksmith
than play with weapons of war at least
make yourself
useful does it burden your heart to kill
your own kind not at all yeah it's cool
they're mindless beasts my Lord no
Brethren of Minds
really father that's sad de dear wait
how do we know Sonia the actress oh
she's been a bunch of stuff okay not I'm
not sure what the best touch Zone would
be I've seen her a thousand times I just
can't she's in like hollow man she was
in uh the practice for a little while
the show yeah I watched that my pops
worked on that I told you to stay Within
These Walls you risk too much for a
father to ignore and why father is my
risk any greater than theirs they are
not my daughters I do not care about
them remember what he did to
[Music]
Sonia wait what he did to his daughter
oh that's her right that's right eight
oh my god without the loyalty between us
we are no better than the beasts at our
door I'm devastated right now maybe
we'll change the
past that is the sexiest Michael Sheen
it really is on every timeline really is
oh my God I'm so glad he's back I want
to watch him and son you get it on like
Donkey Kong forget the plot in the world
building let's just make this a an adult
[Music]
film I
can no W
dog IL sfm you know IL sfm I love you so
effing much Ah that's close she's a good
guy I said that's enough so says the
Master's dog you will not always be his
favorite and when you fall I will be
there let us hope so a excited to watch
him take your head off although I have a
feeling probably all the lyans are going
to get to kill him together we are under
attack six times in half as many weeks
Williams kind have reached our very
walls just say six times in three
weeks got to make a poetic man and how
would you project strength our death
dealers Patrol the night so our daylight
guards can Patrol the day lyans Patrol
outside the walls have you lost your
mind we can create a PR pred class of
lyans Greater rations finer quarters and
put them under the hand of one we trust
and then they can Lord over all the
lyans below them the one who saved your
daughter's life today how messed up are
rich people I think we should hear her
thoughts in this matter don't they're
the best people Roxy they're the people
we should
emulate he's like no no it's not just
it's the privileged ones yeah bro what
it would be gratifying to be able to
reassure the Nobles when they arrive
tomorrow that we have their interests at
heart
yes of course the Nobles you must cuddle
the
Nobles Lucian is a smoke yeah boy and so
is Sonia it's all I'm thinking about
come on Moses lead your people to
Freedom this movie is for the horn dogs
and I love that for us all franchise is
for the do for sure it's the best of
both worlds you get cool horror sci-fi
World building and you get sex
sweaty people long hair yeah it's just
like why is Lucian so much SE sweatier
than everybody else and
sexier they come hand in hand for the
people for the people they Market tested
this and they're like we need more
glycerin on this guy
[Music]
glyer I do feel like there's very
specific sound design on this third
movie that I'm really
enjoying feels different than the first
two well I like being kind of all set in
this Dark Ages period of the the
lineage like the Cyber as I said before
I think like the Cyber Punk stuff is
still super cool but I I love going to
the past with this
franchise he's going to end up dead yes
in this
[Music]
movie knew
it there's something else I know know
her from yeah it'll hit
me she's in that apocalypse movie by the
guy did The
Descent
yes is he biting her hair slow-mo
closeup love making scene stop going to
Black and just stay on
them this reminds me of the the love
scene in
300 I don't prefer the Fade to Black
over and over again give me the action
yeah man Evol wowe okay I mean that was
a good shot I like that shot they're
very smiley yeah they're experiencing
ecstasy for the first time you think
this is the first time no they're
they're sneaking Something Beautiful
under the watchful eye of tyranny if
that's the only time we see it this
movie I'm going be disappointed well
especially after Evolution like went
pretty hard on like the woo look at all
the
body son if I were to leave from
here would you come with me come with me
now she looks like mini ever yeah
definitely oh good call they would hunt
you down and they would Mark you like
all the others not if I could remove
this look I made it oh Lucian promised
me he won't use it is that your answer
then you will not come so you want me to
stay here for you he looks like Rob
Zombie circuit
2003 the educated horses era and I will
leave this place but I can never be
without you now I can never be without
her because it's romantic AF yeah bro
I'm with you make out make out don't
keep fading to Black bro yeah show us
the goods the second we get the kiss and
it comes to to the black it just fades
it just goes into the
darkness come on baby let my fire your
father has ordered you to stay behind I
intend to see our guest safely through
the gate your father is ruler of the
cover so he keeps reminding me ha
ha careful blacksmith lest your eyes
betray your secret oh got goooo
eyes
[Music]
wof you can smell them yeah get get your
men out there now down boy alici is too
tight there's too many of them they'll
be
Massac let's
go it
work
oh
who oh my
God
wow
damn oh it's my
dude with the crazy deep
voice are these the
Nobles they don't seem like Noles yeah
and I mean you know you got all these
people sacked up too
like
wow they up the Carnage a little
bit no save oh my god well we know she's
going to be okay because her dad kills
her don't remind
me just want to bask in their Mutual
Beauty
a red Sonia yep the origin story
you should know
yeah
woof is he going to bite Kevin Grievous
at some point they're going to try to
kill
him oh yeah his face is different shape
and everything
damn you will be our
King oh no oh no oh no come on guys no
that's so tragic like to be
indoctrinated to Massacre your own am I
not master of this
house oh bad dog your days are plush
living are over
slave wonder if Bill Nye became friends
with Kevin Grievous cuz I think he's in
like I Frankenstein too or something
like
that what happened to the noes moving
the color not so Noble no
more I love how there are so many like
opulent fashionable costumes in the
background yeah yeah I gave you your
life you gave me chains you cannot have
one without the other you cannot have
one what without the other without my
daughter without one My Chains No we not
about the daughter I told you I'd be
there when you you fell what are they
going to do beat him oh yeah they're
going to go biblical on
him who's the blond girl just another
not Julia
Styles
oh this could stir up the others let
them stir do you feel and believe me it
will be worse if we do not punish them
you would trust them outside the walls
we cannot even trust them inside oh
that's 21 continue 21 of how many you
know just until he feels like it's
enough
wow 21 out of a of a lot stay away from
him well they'll punish you too he right
those are the slaves of the
Nobles a Kevin Grievous guy sympathetic
have you no gratitude for the one who
saved your daughter's life I am a wash
wom that he lives shows the breadth of
my magnanimity were at any other
circumstances I would have had him fed
in pieces to his own kind
magnanimity he will remain in prison a
cautionary tale yanosh and the other
Nobles will soon arrive your presence is
expected yeah Nobles this wasn't even
the Nobles that came this is the first
wave they probably know you know what
they probably like hey hey you know
shit's probably going to go down when we
get there we should send some peasants
ahead of time are you afraid of me yes
well do not be I will not bite I am a
good boy you are like them no the swor
of William pure Bloods if you I saw you
they oby you yes they did that is wild
he must be wondering about that you
should not be here I had to I cannot
remain here I have to leave this place
but my father will be watching you now
more than ever what about your death de
lesser than none that you can trust
Tannis canot be trusted no Tannis he
knows about us God damn it fing Tannis
Tannis always make mixing things up
shaking it up he's got the
tea all right guys what do you got these
are the Nobles yep Mankind's
finest I like that they brought it in
silver do you not own the largest silver
mine in these lands it has been overrun
my Lord our workers infected turned to
beasts and whose fault is that and have
learned of the deaths of Baron Kasher
and his family the wolves are at your da
you cannot so much as protect your own
house going to die in two seconds this
place is cursed and the Devils that inv
made our land oh yeah UNH me certainly
oh poor choice words my guy ah
ow I'm get your
slap there's always been evil people
power corrupts is this what you want to
be their entertainment their play things
and then fighting amongst ourselves is
this what you
want we do have a choice we can be
slaves or we can be
Lans yes I would follow follow him yeah
man and for the ideas not just because
he's sexy there are some difficult
decisions ahead I would like your help
with one of them of course father we
need to redo the drapes in this Atrium I
think she didn't know how to get away
with murder we must promote another lyan
in his place perhaps gor or thasos I
will consider them strong and then take
credit for them when I
decide you match our most precious thing
in my heart
you have no heart is this a device meant
to control it's a ring cam yeah like
does it also have blades and explode
like before GPS
tracker what have you told my father
would your father welcome the man who
brought him news that his beloved
daughter was Consulting with a lyan he
isn't well known for his gratitude I
mean sure he is he he'll let uh Lucian
live in Chains yeah to show the breath
of his uh yeah gratitude can you keep a
secret I will need something in return I
love her yeah she's a badass Seline also
great but very much enjoying Sonia God
everything in this world is drippy moist
how weird is it to not have the star of
underworlds underworld tree right yeah
you're right he will help us in exchange
for a seat on the council and your
father knows nothing I'm sure of it oh
not sure of it my father will have you
killed tomorrow after the humans return
you must leave at sunrise the best
chance you have is when Victor and the
death dealer sleep if this plan works
I'll meet you in 3 days time after the
sunsets oh no oh man I'm rooting so hard
for these two I know it's doomed I know
I know it's like an epic this is some
just an epic epic Love Story it's like
and Romeo and Vamp Juliet but it's not
lust it's love what don't you understand
might be might be might be I just don't
know what love is
man my key consider departing gift I
knew I kind of sort of liked a little
bit of you
tennis he's going to end up dead in this
movie that's right in this movie they're
going to kill him back to life never
going to come back in the franchise ever
again how would you feel if this movie
had come out first you know I don't know
like I'm really liking this and I can
also very much see why people were so
excited in the comments but I don't know
do you need what came before to really
drive it home no do you not realize this
is a gift I am giving you it's a curse
yeah you don't even like these people
man oh they're having him turn that
Sunrise I leave this place and anyone
willing to take the risk may follow me
there is a new life waiting Beyond these
walls my friend and you can be a part of
it one of us one of us one of us full
moon baby it's always a full moon when
you need it that's right man there were
a lot of more of them back then yeah is
it half full or half
empty
let's
go oh yeah that's what you
get I'm friends with the monster that's
on
my what a shot transition God you me yes
I am so
with anywhere you want to go bro how
dare us ever have doubted him I know I
feel so terrible about my attitude
during the first movie before I knew the
truth the truth will set you free it's
true Crystal the others the rest of you
with
me they all still have their chain their
chokers on right I think so except for
Lucian let's hope that key works on
every single one I don't think it does
what do you think that um Sonia is going
to think of this because I don't think
she realized he was going to set
everybody free I think I mean yeah yeah
I think she's going to be conflicted but
understanding but also it's going to be
a
mess oh
no she's not going to be able to get out
in 3 days be not
clumsy oh boy
ow keep moving keep moving freaking
Spears oh my God they're having to like
duck under them just once in this life I
want to fire one of those G gigantic
crossbows jeez you can
do I will come back oh that's rough
there's nothing they could
do my Lord Lucian is escaping [__] is
going down in the courtyard my Lord
don't vampires have a good sense of
hearing too like did he not know
anything was up he was listening to
other things at the time oh no oh no
oh
yeah whoa into the
light
yeah go go always land on your feet how
many of them got
out got stand there in the sun just to
make a point where is the key I gave you
for this I locked it in the armor myself
how then is it open I have no idea kill
his daughter oh check the Armory there
has to be an explanation interesting did
not all make it out now we not leave our
brothers to rot back there so we have no
weapons the noble who brought you here
can you lead us back to his
estake yes got to have a blacksmithing
Montage make some weapons oh yeah let's
get some swords in here but like you
guys are the weapons too you got to get
those things off your necks true oh they
but they don't have them yet has to be
here
he must have made another one almost was
willing to kill you any man who fights
with me shall have his freedom and
immortality oh yeah everyone who wants
to become a like in for a line over here
there are other states to the west of
here I want you to go there see how many
will join us I will meet you back here
in 2 days time rise of the Lans two days
time at any hour yeah just roughly two
days just just just wait chill be on
this rock in 2 days
time a cursed wind
hows is it her no what is oh what what
oh no that's just him you thought it was
her I thought it was her yeah I did too
at got me excited they both have very
pretty hair
true oh oh he found all of
the the original ones oh yeah
damn wow this is interesting he's like
do I bring them with
me nice alien shot did you help him
Escape of course not he is right you
leave me no choice yeah blood
memories ah I love you you have betray
me I you more than anything she does not
leave this room she going to let have to
let her hair down now so that Lucian can
climb up like did she forget that he
could bite her neck and now would just
think he would never do that yeah I
think she just made the play on like he
won't do it to me has there been any
sign of Sonia she is deceived you she
could leave them here death dealers will
undoubtedly be on the hunt and they will
eventually find us but not by her doing
attitudes like yours lead to conflicts
like this in the first place yep you
need to bring your pet back thank you
Colman the obvious Escape I do not need
to lift a finger Lucian will return of
his own free will no [__] suak Sonia has
been arrested he knows about the two of
you I thought you should know did you do
that of your own valtion I don't know
out of respect for Sonia I thought you
should know do you think I look more
like a wolf or a vampire vampire but you
make a good
wolf
everyone waits in
anguish God he's so sexy how how they I
know it's not fair I've never seen
Michael Sheen in this this kind of thing
yeah like what do we remember did he
burn his daughter into the sun yeah she
tied to that P and they let the sunlight
in just fascinating me this just feels
like a whole other Michael Sheen from
any other role I've seen I'm so with you
I know I was I was stuck on it for a
minute like how did this happen how did
I miss this and how after this did they
not continue to cast him as like sexy
God are you all right yes delution you
were free not without
you we have to go now no no don't open
that door oh it was open don't go
through that door it's okay sometimes
it's so dark I don't know what's going
on yeah your daughter has ES
escaped of course
sh what would you do in her position man
was he holding a little trinket had a
face on it oh
[Applause]
no oh
damn yeah let's get that Heavy Rain
going this is so sad because just let
them be in love they'll never let them
live laugh or
love
[Applause]
oo yeah she's sick let's go at the very
end of this movie that this has to we
have to flash forward to see Kate Beck
in sale right I would imagine but you
never know I
mean ow oo the the back of the neck I
haven't seen that before NE would your
head go forward I guess
so how dare you rap your handle I do not
want this I am your father I am your
daddy nice hops man think you can defeat
me I don't want to defeat you I just
want to be with my boo killing me won't
save your precious like please call off
your men for the sake of your
grandchild let's go that sing inside you
is a
monstrosity oh no oh no whoa remove him
what is she going to do right now oh boy
where are all the rest of them I'm back
at Camp I guess no you think he rode
solo none of the lyans came to have his
back what are you crazy they got I
failed you the choices I made have led
me here you said yourself there are
risks that you were willing to take for
me open the door I like her a lot I
haven't seen her be like a lead to this
extent oh
damn
woo oh
no Silva I want rise of the lake and
straight up come in and rip [__] up you
never known there's still time you have
killed your own kind punishment for
these crimes is death would you be
saying the same thing if it was a dude
council member and Lucian was a girl I I
hate that
[__] I she'll die take her to the
chamber like you know it's coming but
still heartless soulless come on man
open your dead old heart imagine how
creepy it would be to bite somebody and
see your kid having sex with somebody
like I just wanted a
snack how many times has my man's been
whipped in this movie
ow oh please be the
lyans oh it's the sun yeah opening the
Skylight I love you oh I of
you this is torture this is actual
torture I so badly want them to make it
your face will not be here when this is
over with it she said your face will not
be here when it's over will it goodbye
my love oh what does that mean his face
will be she's not going to see him on
the other side ah
oh damn I like this part three and we're
still giving it our all you know I mean
that that was like truly the worst thing
that we've seen happen yet I feel like
to make him watch that and just like the
amount of Anguish like it's it's
tangible sick yeah I hate him it's well
done cuz you know it's coming and you're
just hoping against all hope that some
kind of random Divergence will change
the ti why I guess the question is now
how does Lucian get
out is that what he gives to Kate back
in sale I think so becomes part of the
mechanism that her father's building
right oh
yeah
damn if only you could have hulked out
earlier he grabbed it no it's the
necklace he
had
[Music]
wowe that werewolf boy that effect is
lovely I feel like the other wolves are
going to come help him the L are about
to rise but not just the people lyans
the lyan lyans the original ones yeah so
that necklace I feel like did Lucian
have it and that's where they got it
from his dead body right right cuz there
are two of them yeah cuz he's got the
one no he just took it from Lucian just
took
it yes you can feel them in your
bones can't tell if it's day for night
or not if what the exterior shot is if
it's day for night or not kind of looks
like it oh
yeah
there's so many of them let's
go damn I just wish they had come a
little earlier I know right might have
saved your girl at that point I almost
feel if they were hindered by the fact
that we've already seen that core moment
of this movie they're like well we can't
have them come and break it
up
I'll go free the others I like too the
building of their relationship that
support him being in the first one and
being like you know one of his close
yeah you know close he also just has the
best voice in the planet oh yeah you
want to
R out there
damn uh just passing on that one key
slowly but surely key of truth will set
you
free
Victor nice little Zoom I wish that we
could see Lucian kill Victor right now I
know right I wish that I could kill
Victor right now absolutely think of how
many of our favorite characters might be
spared come
out what are you going to duck into the
hole in the floor going to jump in the
grate remember Victor thought Ian was
dead oh my god dude come on manow fight
like a ruler what's going to happen
here oh those are the other two who are
asleep what did you say is that Marcus
and uh and the other one who are asleep
you defiled my daughter I love you
killed you
kill is what Marcus the two um you know
big old coffin you know mechanized
things that tnis is escaping with
yeah
oh oh wow right through the chains ooh
son
ah come on dude you're so close change
the time line I should have crushed you
under my heel until you were born yes
you should have
remember he was put to sleep so maybe
that this is how I guess yeah is this
special water is this Lazarus Pit ra
ghoul is going to come get him yes and
it's like he's not ridiculously ripped
but it's just enough man that's how I
like
it gu should be in a Grunge music video
right
now what's happening out here is looking
upon his new kingdom this is just the
beginner yes it is damn fast forward do
you think or no yes or no I don't yes or
no I don't think so I'm gonna say no I'm
GNA say no Flash Forward
oh witty
Jack of
course not even going to show us how it
happened a damn you Tannis y he's
getting in in the chamber ah you're a
good chaotic neutral about your beloved
dark father oh you got your Flash
Forward you who reminded him so much of
his precious Sonia of
course Li God I
wonder lies
damn oh snap Patrick topis directed this
he's an fx guy Danny MC bride the Danny
MC footfist ways Danny McBride yes Danny
uh Patrick topis yeah he I think he did
the effects for the first couple and uh
and yeah he was like one of the judges
on face off and stuff he's done a bunch
of like production design and and effect
so Len didn't do this one so then she
didn't do like they were like no this is
a couple sing only now I wonder if maybe
I mean he had like a story credit which
you know could certainly be just that
like oh you know you helped yeah you you
clearly laid foundation for what this is
resting on top of but um but yeah you
got your Flash Forward man I guess that
was the thing I was like I don't think
they'll they'll do new footage no I just
thought that there would be like some
kind of tie into the universe to remind
people who kind of forgot that because I
do feel like you and I have been
watching these back to back relatively
you know in a few weeks time but
immediately you were like oh oh yeah
because you forget that we heard this
story from Lucian yeah yeah yeah so I
think for some people who had been years
since they heard that probably they were
like oh [__] that's right at the end oh
yeah yeah and there are you know names
and things to keep track of and and you
know various McGuffin and aspects of the
lore that was very good for I can't
believe that for a third movie they kept
us on our toes that way yeah it was
really different yeah coming at it from
the liky and
perspective and already having known the
outcome of the story and still being on
our toes yeah I thought this for the
most part did really nicely to get
around you know just the the the
Troublesome aspect of making a prequel
where you know part of the things that
are going to happen especially in this
context where we've seen this traumatic
event that is so uh you know close and
personal to Lucian you know we've SE
seen this flashback so many times and I
thought they managed to yeah like make
the lead up to that and make all the
different
circumstances uh just yeah sing to the
point where there was still suspense and
I was still really invested even though
yeah you know certain things are going
to happen I think I think the only thing
uh and I and I'll give them a pass
because it's so late on in the movie but
you know like he does kind of we get to
have our cake and eat it too and then he
kills uh Victor but he doesn't really
kill Victor
we like how did he survive that you know
I guess he just didn't kill him enough
cuz he's the vamp of all Vamps you know
like I think that that I'll definitely
give them that one he's got special Juju
and they didn't even wait till the next
movie to explain they explained pretty
quickly yeah you like know he going to
and we knew Tannis had also had been um
excommunicated or whatever but not
killed yeah and I almost wonder if maybe
they went back and they're like ah could
we put a little button on the end like
maybe test audiences were were like but
is he dead I thought he's dead He's
Alive you know so maybe they just added
that back in but this felt very much so
big more big budget than the other
movies I felt like with all I mean just
the amount of wolves in this yeah like
all the wolves and even though you're
not going a ton of different places it
still felt like we really saw a lot of
this Castle compound that the vampires
are in and the outdoors of it
surrounding areas and it makes sense why
we wouldn't span too far beyond that but
we still get like the Lykan caves and
all that stuff and there's all this rain
and like the action the gore effects and
everything like you know this this isn't
quite as pulpy in just pound-for-pound
flesh and blood as the previous I feel
like especially Evolution I feel like
Evolution kind of upped the the ante in
terms of like let's get some real gor
gags and let's get some steamy sexy
scenes in here um whereas this you know
I think made certainly good on all those
aspects but did uh more with just like
the sheer intensity and Desperation of
the context of the situation you know
how do you feel about Sonia I like Sonia
a lot like I I loved the two of them I
liked her character a bunch I almost
wonder especially at the end there
because they remind you of like you know
oh Seline you remind him so much of his
Sonia and I'm like did she audition to
be Seline and you know get really close
and then they were like well maybe down
the line they are similar I got to see
what I know her whether and I'm trying
to think if she was I can't fully recall
if uh she is the same actress in The
flashbacks from the original movie or
not did we see those flashbacks we at
least see flashes of them but they're
filtered yeah so I'm trying to remember
if that was her or if yeah she's just
obscured or something so let me see but
I really liked her performance she was
in Supergirl so definitely that yeah
she' been in a million things but she a
any of the things that I thought she was
in no what's that literally n there's an
Apocalypse movie that she did uh with
the guy who directed like dog soldiers
and stuff like that that I can't
remember the name year are you looking
at it's like the mid 2000s or something
like this doomsday I think is the name
of that movie I'll tell you if I get
there well none of the things that I
thought she was doomsday yeah I've never
seen that no FAL and legal in the
practice I guess that's just where I
know we're from no she I thought her
performance was really good like I I
really liked her presence I I thought
like she was an Alig G in the house hey
okay but yeah no I thought that I mean
you know I love watching Kate beckin
sale in this but I feel like this movie
gives you sort of a greater opportunity
to be a bit more intimate with a
character in this position who
is even though she has some of that
stoic badass quality she's like a little
more emotive and I thought just yeah the
different flavors from like the badass
you know Warrior side of her character
to the tender you know like you know
desperate lover side of her character I
thought was great and I loved her
chemistry with uh Michael Sheen I
thought she played well off of uh Bill
Nye as well like I thought she was great
like I I I really loved her presence
here and it's cool because again like
again no shade like I really love
watching Kate Beck and sale as Seline
and in that context of the story um but
I think this is the one like the first
two I enjoyed and they grew on me in
reviewing them to put these videos up as
I you know reviewing the footage and
stuff like that and this one I think is
the one that most immediately has kind
of uh you know just like gripped and
dazzled me yeah you know like this one
yeah I think you're right it's like it
it's it feels a little higher budget or
something or there's something just like
a little more thick about the production
values and it feels a little bit more
Rich to me in this presentation
this movie was the first one that's a
true love story like the other ones the
love elements are in them but I feel
like that this start to finish was which
is why I think you guys at home thought
I would like it best and I did and I and
I do think that it's shining a little
bit of a a light on the fact that this
is the Dark Ages yeah and they had a
problem with a wolf and a vampire being
together fast forward to where we are
and there was a problem with the wolf
and the vampire being together and it's
like times change but bigots don't yeah
like I really do feel like there's a
direct obviously like they're they're
they're making a point about um
interracial relationships and marriages
or just like two different people from
different backgrounds of any sort coming
together and I do think it's interesting
to go back in time and see that much um
vital and hate for the this couple to
the where you would kill your own
daughter and then we flash forward to
when Kate beckin sale um is falling in
love uh and they come into the room and
they find out that gra Anatomy Scott
spean that he is a uh what they what's
his name Michael Michael yeah hybrid
that Michael is a hybrid and it's how
dare she be in love with him you know
that's a horrible thing to do and that
is all those years later and it's just
the times some people just never get
with the times yeah well and it's like
you know here we come so close to having
the hybrid born you know it's like your
grandson and all that stuff and then
that light is snuffed out we see it
centuries down the line um yeah it's
like I thought this tied together really
nicely and I thought it like one thing
I've appreciated about the movies across
the board is like the first to have
their all three of them have you know
their Fun World building and especially
the first to have you know your your
cyberpunk elements and stuff like that
but they all have that you know slight
allegorical quality and I think this one
did it the most densely but yeah it's
like the first one you've got Selene
waking up to you know this
indoctrination realizing like that the
society she's grown up in and the truth
that she's been you know sold is not the
truth is not you know uh the actual you
know way it's not um as it seems and
it's not you know for her protection
it's based on oppression and and things
like that and she has to realize like oh
these people who I thought were you know
the good guys and and I thought I was on
the right side of things now I have to
wake up to that and then you know you
get that kind of further explored in the
second movie and then here yeah it's
like you know it's systematic oppression
and slavery and all sorts of things and
I thought that and and you know it's
it's a Sci-Fi B movie in a lot of ways
it's a you know Monster movie and stuff
so it's not like the wokest thing ever
but I thought that the way that they
portrayed the struggle of the lyans and
bothered to incorporate the peasant
humans into that was kind of nice
because I think in a lot of these
allegories you'll get like um you know
here's your your special kind of
character whether it be like AI robots
or it's werewolves or whatever it is and
and they're the sort of Cipher for
Injustice and intolerance and there are
other groups that you know in history
have you know been really subjected to
that and they're kind of fine and
everyone's only prejudiced against this
one kind of magic thing and I like that
here you know you have that most focally
on the lyans but they bother to
incorporate you know the human peasants
into that too to kind of create this
intersection of struggle and just kind
of like a the greater grander scheme of
like oh yeah there are lots of like
weird allegiances and and you know
political games being played and yet the
vampires clearly are kind of oppressing
everyone around them for their own gain
yeah so yeah it's like you know there's
there's more meat on the bone than there
needs to be and I think this one out of
all of them I think because it really
threw itself into the desperate love
story and just the struggle yeah it just
felt like kind of the richest of the
three in terms of those things all
coming together and me not going
like me not being as as much like okay
and now we're going to kind of take a
break from that stuff and we're going to
have be movie fun like it kind of felt
like this one was doing all of them all
the time mhm yeah I hear you on that I I
think that um you're you liked that they
added in that more human element one of
the things that I like that they touched
on that they haven't talked about that
much in the other movies is the original
beasts because we've talked we talked in
other movies about how you know that
that's they couldn't turn back um which
I think it always we had this judgment
towards them and so does Lucian being
like I'm not like them I'm not like them
but at the end of the day those are the
people who have your back and also they
didn't and they in know to follow you
even though yeah they didn't choose this
life yeah and I just think that it is it
was really interesting I think a lot of
times we all fight we fight against our
own people sometimes and it's like but
I'm not like that I'm not like that and
at the end of the day it's like but if
those are the people who are in your
corner it's very hard to like what makes
you not like that that fact that you
were given the choice that they weren't
that the fact that you are able to
actually turn back um and he kind of had
turned his back on his own at the
beginning saying it doesn't pain me to
hurt them in any way and it's like you
know and then by the end it's
like they but they are part of you yeah
it's like I thought maybe for a moment I
thought that what they were telling me
about like oh yeah I am the
sophisticated version of this I am you
know the better version of this I'm the
one who's worthy to at least exist in
some Capac capity you know among the
civilized society and and I I like that
yeah you you have the vampires who
clearly are just like any liking it's
just in your nature you know you're
you're just a bad feral thing and so
with you know the yeah the ones who are
The Originals who can't turn back or
anything like that I like having that
flip side of like well there is some
kind of instinctual order when they see
Lucian and so like yeah it's like as
much as you could say there's innate
savagery there's also some kind of
innate Community as well exactly and if
instead of just killing them there had
been any kind of effort to like reason
or speak to or whatever there might have
been clearly they aren't just Savages
with no order you know so I did think
that that was interesting too we had in
the other movies I had kind of written
them off like oh that generation of them
they were just Savage and it's like cuz
that's what we're told um which is what
Seline thinks cuz that's what she's told
you know so I do I do think that going
backwards made us go deeper into this
lore and then move there's more of these
right there's I think there's like five
or six in total yeah so moving forward
I'm sure that just the more knowledge
you have on this world the cooler the
the world is yeah and I mean I I think
this this again does nicely to be like a
fun Punchy experience on its own but it
also bolsters the movies that came
before you're asking like I'm I think
the only thing that would you know kind
of be Ed by watching them you know
having this one be the first one you
watch is just you won't have that a big
shoe drop for Selene in the first movie
cuz you'll just kind of know what the
nature of things is and you'll be
waiting for her to catch up to it yeah I
like this order way better I think this
is so much smarter yeah cuz it's like
you know the first two can kind of draw
you into the world and and they're all
fun but the first two are a bit more I
think prioritizing the fun scale maybe a
little bit more than this and like the
badassness whereas this you know yeah I
just think had like a real nice balance
and it did it like really
straightforward really Nifty it didn't
feel too long didn't feel too short a
lot of great actors across the board I
like that they've been able it's always
kind of impressive when they're able to
maintain the longevity of like yeah
people will keep coming back to be in
these movies and and even though we're
at part three of something that does
have be movie to some degree in its DNA
everyone's freaking given it their all
like actors to the caliber and I grant
this is earlier in time but like still
like a bill Nike and a Michael Sheen and
all these people don't have to be going
up to 11 you know really selling the
anguish but yeah they didn't pH it in
they just really really showed up do you
know what my least favorite part of the
movie is list try to take gu the not
super sexy sexy scene The Cutting to
Black The Fading to Black why did you
guys Fade to Black over and over you
have an R rating you had an R rating
where are you fading to Black over and
over if Patrick topis had just married
Rona MRA it would be a totally different
scene that's what I'm saying cuz that's
the thing is in the in evolution yeah
you you have that like o we're drinking
in every curve and we're suggesting a
whole lot and it is steamy and this one
yeah was like it's it's a little steamy
yeah but show me show me the good show
me the love I just wanted R you got you
have your r r m yeah this is is in the
gore department but yeah this one in a
weird way felt less R-rated than the
other two felt less R-rated you
espcially in the second one the second
one feels the most irrated I think is it
time for us to fade to black I think
it's time for us to fade the black oh
this has been such a blast though I've
really like I've grown to love this
franchise and this one was a dunk I
didn't know that you and me that for I
feel like for different reasons but
similar reasons we just were underworld
St yeah man I'm a lover of love and a
shipper of ships as well and then you
add the Spooks and uh you know the the
little bit of thought in there a little
bit of relevancy like you're doing more
than you need to do and I salute that
Ron joxy Ron joxy dude that was the best
double high five I even need to look at
your elbows you can't if it's two cuz if
it's two how you going to do it the back
forth and then I hit you in the face is
there a special someone we need to give
some love to I think we're done for the
month then I just going to give love to
everybody at home love to all you guys
just love to everybody thank you guys
Happy spook spooky season or the end of
spooky season or whatever season comes
next who knows what time is anymore go
all the Thanksgiving movies yes do this
I wanted to finish Underworld for
Thanksgiving it's very family themed
family oriented built on a troubled
history you know a difficult to rectify
in modern times history based on a lot
of dubious Deeds oppressions otherwise
thematically it's a fit and and Fade to
Black thanks for you
jacks